le jour se lève la Loire se dévoile
guide du pèlerin qui marche au rythme du
soleil la lumière et le fleuve pour
boussole
itinéraire mais je dépendra un peu des
chemins quoi
emboîte aussi s'éveille ville tourner
vers Compostelle
donc là donc apparemment je suis sur le
bon cheval
400 km déjà laissés entre sa Belgique et
la moitié nord de la France
1200 encore droit devant entre le
Sud-Ouest et l'Espagne
je marche sur le bord pour ne pas avoir
trop de bitume quand c'est possible
Christine avance le décor se verdit la
flore impose son odeur sa quiétude le
calme se propose et la loi reste fidèle
je vois des grenouilles j'adore ça j'ai
eu beaucoup de libellules à un moment
donné des papillons aussi donc moi voilà
j'aime être dans la nature
c'est une façon de se reconnecter à soi
aussi marcher pourquoi marcher pour qui
Jacques poursuit son chemin un peu le
sien leur nom est commun mais
l'expérience elle une Ikea intime c'est
pour ça que je continue
voyager le long de ses chemins pour ce
que je vais voir parce que je vais
rencontrer
pour la fatigue et pour le plaisir le
goût de l'effort quand le corps s'épuise
le mental l'épaule le goût du par les
rassoit le goût de la solitude de
l'introspection
c'est à ceux qui mélangent un peu tout
ça
une forme de spiritualité
mais en même temps je suis content de me
prouver qu'elle est après année je
marche encore la marche comme une quête
personnelle l'identité remise en
question le passé a ressasser le futur à
dessiner et le présent à questionner
le fait que je trouve une réponse ou non
à moins d'importance
je suis
Christine aussi marche toujours comme en
2017 avec Compostelle au bout et la
maladie abandonnée au bord du chemin
je sortais d'un burn out
j'avais besoin de
de sortir de cette vie trépidante etc et
de faire quelque chose et ça m'a
beaucoup apporté ce chemin une vie de
surcharge le service communication d'une
grosse entreprise belge trop de tâches
et trop peu nombreux retraites anticipée
longue convalescence et puis le chemin
pour moi ça a vraiment été une thérapie
à 5 ans et ça l'est encore sans doute
que j'ai encore quelque chose à
apprendre de moi-même voilà
tout un été à marcher Christine ira
jusqu'au bout peut-être un peu
transformé dans de moi elle verra
composter alors buenkamino comme il se
disent en se croisant